[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and
today i'm going to be taking you through
some really exciting wins in the one
the only exchange slav defense
we're going to be taking a look at some
old games and some new games
but boy oh boy are they some fun chess
games now of course the exchange slot
as it stated in the title has a bit of a
reputation
for being a more boring opening but
we're gonna see
that there is plenty to play for with
the white pieces
um and we're gonna see how different
players approach the positions
but to start with we are going back in
time
to a world champion by the name of
michael
botfinik and in this game botvanic was
up against
mislove in a head-to-head match so let's
see what was going on
in this game of course the exchange slav
starts the d4 d5
c4 um c6 c takes d5
uh and now you might expect that this is
how this game started
being that the lecture is on the
exchange slot but you would be wrong
the players actually began d4 d5 knight
f3
knight f6 c4 c6 c takes d5
c takes d5 changing approximately
nothing um well jokes aside though
this does change a little bit sometimes
you'll see players with the white pieces
not actually commit this knight to f3
with the idea
of keeping this knight back on g1 and
we're gonna see why that might be a good
idea a little bit later on
but this game we have the knight on f3
in this exchange slot
uh white continued by developing the
second knight with knight c3
now we have knight c6 and batman
continues
with the move bishop to f4
nowadays a lot of players really prefer
to get this bishop outside the pawn
chain with the black pieces
as well and while that is a really good
idea black is going to have to know some
stuff
if you do want to play a move like
bishop f5 here
um and what is that stuff we have to be
well prepared to meet the move
queen to b3 whenever you're playing this
move bishop f5
but this is definitely playable for
black
but just by virtue of being a move ahead
white can make black's life a little bit
more difficult if black does try to
follow suit with total symmetry and get
this bishop outside the pawn chain
all that being said smith's love
actually goes e6
in the game and i can tell you playing
the exchange slot myself just
practically
over the board and online you do face a
lot of players that are willing to just
play e6
and say okay i don't need my bishop
outside my pawn chain
you're playing the exchange slot it's
not like i'm going to be under that much
danger and they'll just go e6 now in my
opinion
this is actually going to be a less
accurate
line for black than bringing the bishop
outside the pawn chain
it's just a little bit less than
comfortable to have this bishop back
here on c8
so let's see how white tries to take
advantage of it because of course the
position is still
quite symmetrical uh symmetrical pawn
structure and black is going to get
developed and castled quite quickly well
we see e3 by podfinit nothing crazy yet
bishop e7 is mislav's choice keeping
this bishop on the board rather than
going bishop d6 which is also possible
simply bishop d3 by buffinic kingside
castles
by black and then a nice little subtlety
here
by white he goes h3 sort of anticipating
that if you do castle black may on
occasion
be interested in capturing your bishop
so h3
giving this bishop a little hidey hole
before getting castled
bishop d7 is now the move by black while
this bishop is not doing great outside
the pawn chain
it does want to leave the back rank in
order to
free up something like this like the c8
square and also potentially come back
to e8 where it can help defend the
king's side
kingside castles by white is played now
we see a6 by black
a very common move uh preparing perhaps
a b5 break
when black will look to take over the c4
square now we see
the very simple rook c1 by white so far
so normal right this is exactly what you
would expect to see
from an exchange slot that's why i'm
sort of going through these moves rather
quickly
nothing too crazy is happening just yet
but we'll see
that's you know while the position does
remain very symmetric
we're gonna see white is able to force
some imbalances here
rather quickly bishop e8 is
mislove's choice which i do think is a
little bit of a strange move
normally you see black try to contest
the c file advance the play on the queen
side with b5
or get this queen activated as well
something like queen
a5 if i could draw the arrow with the
point being that a lot of the time
you will be able to bring this rook out
to c8 before playing the move
bishop e8 but smith's love plays bishop
e8 right away which
my opinion is a little bit of a strange
move
uh and now botfinec plays bishop back
to b1 and here some interesting things
start happening already with the way
that smith love is played
i think he understood that he was
actually going to be on the worst end of
things
on the queen side of the board given
enough time white is going to be able to
take over
on this side of the board with moves
like knight a4 and knight c5
for example let's say black still tried
sort of stubbornly
to play on this side of the board
something like you know
just the move rook c8 for example
already i think white has a myriad of
options
but even queen d3 is going to be
playable or prefaced with
a3 as well to stop knight to uh to b4
and now something like knight a5
um again there are going to be a lot of
options here but whenever the knight
leaves the center
it sort of makes way for this knight to
enter and
now it's just going to be awkward in the
long run for black to get this rook into
the game
if the play maintains on the queen side
white is just always going to be a
little bit faster
with this rook ready to join in the
action
in this bishop as well applying some
pressure so
smith's love for better or worse shows a
different approach to this game
and goes knight h5 now knight h5 on its
own
doesn't seem too crazy right you attack
the bishop the bishop retreats back to
h2
but then perhaps number one fearing
some potential activity on this diagonal
and number two
worried about how to solve the problem
of this rook smith's love continues
with this move f5 and
this is a very double-edged idea for
such a so-called
boring opening so chat room i already
want to get your thoughts on this idea
of
f5 let me know what you think here what
is your general feeling of this position
what's your feeling on this position
um
and i will refresh my chat
okay maybe the chat just has no feelings
is the chat feeling less this could be
well i'll tell you
my feeling on the position
okay there they go um peter doesn't like
black's pawn structure probably after
this move f5 noticing that this pawn on
e4 may be a little bit weak
it also is as stated weakening this e5
square a little bit
but in return of course black is getting
a lot more
uh strength in the e4 square and chess
can actually think black has
an easier position and i think that's a
reasonable thing to say
and now the chat already has a very
active idea that
is definitely going to be an important
one and one to keep in mind and that is
f5 is sort of uh for the moment
blocking this diagonal but if something
ever happens to this f pawn
maybe black will live to regret not
having this pawn back on f7 where it can
help defend the light squares
now what's going to happen to this f5
pawn well perhaps the move g4
is going to be a very active idea that
black has to keep an eye on
and while it is sort of playable
immediately
i don't know if we want to be going out
all out just yet over here
it is sort of difficult to imagine how
we're really adding any more attackers
to this side of the board
other than this bishop on this one
diagonal so instead
botvinnik keeps that idea in the back of
his head
and simply continues play on the queen's
side f5
while it does look like a strange move
that's no reason to
sort of abandon our plan over here of
improving our knights
playing on this side of the board and
botfunic just continues naturally with
knight a4 now smithslav does decide
it's time to kill this bishop and goes
bishop to d6
bottofnet continues with knight c5 take
on h2
take on h2 and now queen e7
and now is the time to find some
concrete ways
to uh solidify the advantage here with
white so how do we solidify this
advantage
we're going to start turning it into
something very very concrete
very shortly
mccarthy says totally boring
well it may might not stay totally
boring
for too very much longer
unless he just means you know me in the
lecture in general in which case i
cannot help you
so chess king says the move f4
and i'm seeing a lot of noise in the
chat about
dedicating your life to putting a piece
on the e5 square and i just don't think
that that
is really the way to go here um if we
really wanted to we could play something
like
knight d3 over to e5 we could put all of
our pieces focusing on this square
and we might even achieve you know
putting a knight there but
i don't think this is going to be a
winning idea
the knight and e5 might be a good piece
but it's not really working
with white's other pieces right it puts
a little pressure on the c
file but but really i don't think that's
going to make too big of a difference
and playing a move like f4 is definitely
going to be a little bit too weakening
right you know we saw black weakening
some squares with the move at five
but it's not really an excuse for white
to just go ahead and weaken all the same
squares
with something like f4 for example
knight g3 knight e4
and black is sort of doing this plan
better than white here if we ever take
either pawn takes let's say this one and
it's already going to be difficult for
us
to keep control over all these squares
in our own camp
so what's um botfnet goes ahead and does
is first of all just increases the
pressure on the clean side with the move
queen b3
we see rook f7 and then he does
something
really really great he starts playing on
both
sides of the board now why is that such
a good deal
well it's always sort of a balance in
chess of figuring out
if you can break through on one side of
the board just by piling up your pieces
there
or if it's better to stretch your
opponent's pieces then
with you know that principle of two
weaknesses
generally that's sort of stated as an
end-game principle
but it works quite often in middle games
as well
very useful to know by sort of
stretching the black pieces thin playing
on both sides of the board
bottom is able to create threads
everywhere
while the black pieces are just not able
sort of to parry everything
and what's the way to do that well it's
with the chat rooms move from earlier
now is the right time to play the move
g4
breaking down black's light square
blockade of this long diagonal
um you're not able to just save the
knight because i will take on f5
and win a pawn so f takes g4 is needed
now h takes g4 forces the knight back
and botfonic does now follow up with the
move f4
although it is of course under very
different circumstances
now botfunic is happy to play f4 because
of course
botfinic is keeping control over this
square
on e4 versus the other variation when
black was able to quite
uh easily occupy that square
now unfortunately uh smith's love sort
of cracks under the pressure already
although i will say
i think white is quite close to just
having a strictly winning position
outright um the move that smith love
tries
is b6 which is a pretty interesting pawn
sacrifice
the idea is after queen takes b6 rook b8
is coming and now after queen takes a6
the idea i imagine was to break through
uh on with rook takes b2 now let's take
a look and see what happens if
smithslav doesn't play like this uh what
do you think
uh bot fenix idea was if smith's love
just played
some sort of normal looking move um like
rook to c8 here how would play continue
from here
um and in the chat dylan asks wouldn't
b6 kick the knight off of c5
well for the moment as stated queen
takes v6 would be the idea
and yes steve was wondering how to
activate this bishop well you're looking
at it you're looking at it with this g4
idea
so the idea is going to be while we wait
for the
delay to catch up here it is actually
going to be g5 in this case
what's the big deal with g5 well this is
removing
the last sort of defender of these light
squares around the black king
this knight also really doesn't have
anywhere to go if it comes to d7 it's
going to be interfering with the defense
of the b7 pawn
it comes to e4 it's just going to get
captured g4 is unavailable
and of course the last square is h5
where it
can in fact go but now already there are
going to be problems
in black's camp for example queen c2 g6
is
is the best defensive try but now knight
g4 and you can see here
that's um the king side is really
breaking down
for black and don't forget about these
weaknesses on the queen side as well
and this weakness on e6 right black
simply has too much to keep track of
here
and play might continue something like
um rook f8 to step out of the fork
even queen g2 queen h2 which is bringing
the queen over to the king's side
and then let's say black tries to start
pushing over here
on the queen side the simple move knight
d3
knight e5 and as stated white is just
going to sort of
roll over black on the king's side here
just to continue the line let's say b5
knight e5 takes would actually hang a
rook so you can't do that
um queen b7 maybe and
yeah gosh i don't know do i need to go
further like we're not
going to get to the point where it's a
knockout blow but
uh white is just going to keep building
the pressure here and black is sort of
going to be helpless
for example 95 say black just continues
you can take on c8 take on c8 queen d2
bring in a rook and all of black's
pieces are bad
and all of white's pieces are good which
is good enough for me
what was the point of all that well the
point of all that is that smith's love
likely understood
that if he just sort of plays some sort
of slow move
g5 and then these moves like queen c2
knights coming into e5
it's just going to be an awful awful
position for black where none of black's
pieces really makes sense
and this knight in h5 is just dominated
out of the game
so smithslav does go for this
interesting idea of b6
with the point to activate the rook
along the b file now queen takes a6 was
played
and rook takes b2 is likely the best
move
for black here i imagine uh smithslav
saw something wrong with this that he
didn't quite like
but i would like the chat room to try
and figure out what they would play
in this position with white because
black
actually has a really interesting idea
that you have to be on the lookout for
here
black actually does have an idea to look
out for
so let's start with the natural move
what's the natural move
has to be g5 right has to be g5
if you play some sort of i don't know
normal move guess what black is going to
do
black is going to play g5 themself and
after this move your position is going
to get a little bit
awkward if you take on g5 look out for
knight takes g4
highlighting the fact that this knight
is overworked
so scary stuff so let's start with g5
let's start with g5
um what is black going to do after g5
well there's a really killer move here
in the form of e5 and i think this is
what smith love
had in mind in the game so he went for
something very very similar
but unfortunately his line was a little
bit less
accurate
so what's going on after e5 what's going
on well
you might imagine that you can take this
knight on
f6 and you would be correct but after
rook takes
let's say a simple retreating move like
queen d3
now all of a sudden white is actually
dead
lost you heard me right white is dead
lost here
to the idea of e4 if the queen moves out
of the way
richie's six check king h1
rook takes h2 not rook g2 but rick takes
h2
and queen h4 mate so white does have to
be very careful here
because black is on the attack
and it turns out that the best way to
actually win the position
is to play the really kind of but
on the one hand simple on the other hand
uh
sort of a natural move queen a3 you you
just evict this rook
from its post on b2 and then white is
able to win
sort of without consequence rook takes
h2 for example
king takes h2 e takes f4
and you can still take this but maybe
simplest is just to take this guy
and here after a check
knight takes d4 black is definitely
still the one with a lot of activity
but the pieces are coming to the king's
defense in this case and white
is just gonna be winning here um so i
think this is what smith's love should
have gone for
sticking with this rick takes b2 idea in
the game he chose a less accurate move
order with e5
which now does fail to a variety of
moves
for example the simplest is just to take
black's idea was to capture now
but after f takes c5 queen takes e5
white to move and win is pretty simple
you just offer the trade of the queens
and that is the end of story
queen g3 check rook takes b2 does come
but this threat is very easily parried
with
rook to c2 just blocking along the
second rank
and then black resigned shortly after
g5 g6 takes takes
and black had seen enough in this case
so
i really like this game by botfinik why
do i like this game so much
because um it's you know
it sorry um it's great for what he did
do on the board
but it's also great how we see black
sort of just self-destruct
right white didn't do too much special
here
but the point was black's position was
just already uncomfortable out of the
opening
and he felt the need to play these moves
like f5 and that's sort of what
you know tore the game apart so it's
almost just as much a great game
because of the lengths smith's love went
to to avoid just that slow
dominating crush and that's why we ended
up seeing so much action so
critics might say you know this game
isn't so great black just fell apart
with knight h5 and f5
but i think that's what really shows the
power of you know the the opening
choices of both of these players
botfinik managed already by move 12 to
put smith's love in a position
where he felt that this sort of risky
strategy was was necessary this is what
he had to go for
because black white's pieces were just
better placed than
blacks so i want to open it up to any
questions on this
game before we move on to players
arguably even better
than botvenic and smithslove
ben feingold once said that games that
start boring tend to become interesting
later seems to be true here and i don't
know if i've noticed
this tendency i think there are many
examples where games start boring
and then end abruptly without any
interesting things
but i take the point i do think these
these things happen as well
um can white go knight d3 after black
goes
rook b2 let's see what we're talking
about here if rook b2
here knight d3 then i do think this
exchange stack is going to be
going to be a good one as steve north is
suggesting
and why isn't this good after queen a3
um well knight takes g4 king h3
and white is somehow surviving this one
somehow surviving this one although
granted you know the game is definitely
not over
white does have some defenders around
the king still though
but as i say that i think again maybe
this move um
e5 is is going to come in handy for
black once again so
definitely i think rick takes b2 here
would have been the way to go
um in this particular instance of course
rook takes b2 is threatening mate
but yeah the immediate rook b2 i think
would have been a lot more accurate from
smithslav
and it would have put the pressure on
white
quite uh quite a bit and
oh yeah so what i was recommending was
g5 before
queen a3 with the point that now this is
much less dangerous
because there's no queen coming in
that you need to worry about too much
although
this move apparently loses so maybe
there are things to worry about
right maybe there are things to worry
about still
but king h1 and you are keeping these
pieces out
okay let us move on then to game
number two which is going to be a game
between wesley so
and magnus carlson uh
maybe you saw that coming when i said
players even better than dotfinik
but yes magnus with the black pieces has
in fact
actually fallen victim to the power of
the exchange
slav so the next time you feel bad about
losing to a quote-unquote
boring opening you know just think back
to this game between wesley so and
magnus carlsen
and i didn't do um a ton of research
this game is from norway chess in 2018
and maybe this was the last classical
game of chess
magnus have lost before he went on this
long unbeaten streak
i don't actually fully remember but this
was definitely around that time
so you know these are the days when
magnus sort of stopped losing chess
forever
that's how bad this game hurt he lost
this game and he was like i'm just never
gonna lose another game of chess
ever again um so we do get the normal
move order for the exchange slav by the
way
and white chooses bishop f4 rather than
knight f3 in this case
we see knight f6 knight c3 knight c6
and then wesley does go knight f3 here
anyways of course
e3 would be another option with the
point being you can bring this knight to
e2
but again we do see knight f3 now a6
by magnus carlson rook c1 by
wesley so and bishop f5 so in this case
you know these modern day grand masters
they realize it's not good
to shut your bishop in inside the pawn
chain then you have to start playing
like smithslav and doing crazy things
like f5 and nobody wants that
so magnus being the professional that he
is develops his bishop outside his pawn
chain
we see e3 by wesley these queen b3 ideas
probably don't make as much sense
anymore because white hasn't played e3
yet
bishop isn't coming into the action and
this uh tempo with rook c1
isn't exactly helping the action over
here on the queen side
something like knight a5 would likely be
the response and there are plenty of
ways
for black to deal with these these
threats on the queen's side
so e3 instead by wesley
the game continued with rook to c8 by
magnus this is all very much mainline
stuff
bishop e2 by wesley so keeping these
pieces on the board for the moment
e6 now by magnus we get castles
and then magnus does start to go into
slightly more of a sideline right here
the most popular move is bishop d6 with
these bishops
getting traded off rather quickly but
magnus instead
chose the move knight to d7
what's the point of knight to d7 well
you open up this diagonal
uh first of all second of all you are
sort of playing against
white's idea of controlling the e5
square a little bit
and you're bringing this knight into
good position to help contest
things on the queen side of the board as
well
now wesley continues in normal exchange
slav fashion with the move knight
a4 just because black is playing against
this idea
doesn't mean white should stop going for
control of the c5 square it's always
critically important in the exchange
slot positions
to control this square bishop e7 played
now and we again see the the generally
useful move
h3 i want to point out that white is in
no rush
to play a move like knight to c5 white's
also not really in a rush to commit this
queen to any square like you don't
really want to commit
to b3 when knight a5 is available you
don't really want to commit to the d2
square when a knight could still
potentially land on
e4 and in fact if you do start playing
moves like
queen d2 you might even be in a little
bit of danger of a
sort of surprise attack idea by black
here
so black to move after some sort of
nothing move like a3
or or queen d2 what do you what do you
guys think you would play with black
black to move here in the boring boring
boring
exchange slav oh my god it's so boring
uh peter in the chat has also decided to
never just lose a game
he will either win or learn something
that's similar to what magnus has chosen
although i believe magnus is claiming to
have learned enough
and so he's just just not going to lose
and yeah um the russian or the
cyrillic characters in the chat i can't
read those
sadly says g5 and this is the the right
idea g5 is actually really awkward
for white to me bishop g3 for example
and not the immediate g4
when this knight would likely just
retreat but h5
and now you get h4 ideas you have to
play h3 anyways
and all of a sudden white is sort of
getting destroyed
so look out for those ideas if your
opponent ever plays knight d7
before they castle they might not just
be playing for control of these dark
squares
but as i said crucially opening up
this diagonal can be relevant with ideas
of of g5
so wesley anticipated this and played
the move h3
now g5 just simply isn't going to be
good the bishop can go back to h2 in one
turn
and these ideas are just much less
threatening for example 91
you're not in time to play g4 you now
have to go on the defense
to defend your uh h5 pawn with something
like this
and it's just a sad story overall so
h3 magnus decided just to castle and
abandon these g5 ideas for the moment
um now we see white continue with a3
which again some people would say is
boring this is boring chess
why are we looking at this guy play the
move a3
b4 well the fact of the matter is while
these moves
do look sort of more on the subtle side
they are making
huge positional threats at any moment
if either side just starts wasting time
they could find themselves
in a objectively lost position for
example i think in many amateur games
players with the black pieces might say
hey hey my opponent's playing moves like
h3 and a3
surely i have time to make left for for
my king as well and i think after this
move
black is is very seriously close to just
busted just
dead lost for example if you allow this
pawn to get to b4
you allow this knight to get to c5 you
start thinking you have to
capture this guy now pawn takes on c5
you're dealing with a protected pass
pawn you're dealing with the queen side
opening up with
a4 and white is is very very much better
in this position
so once again magnus carlsen a very good
chess player
understands that you know this is not
the simple position that it appears to
be on the surface this is a position
that demands urgency so he responds to
knight a4
with this b4 threat with the move knight
to a5 this is the interesting idea
magnus has what is the point well the
point now
is if you try to continue with the same
idea of
b4 uh it's going to be
sort of a mutual knight in each other's
side like you know thorn in the side but
it's a knight
the point is white gets this knight to
c5 but
black is also getting their own knight
to uh to c4
um and that's exactly what happens in
the game
under slightly different move orders we
see knight c5 first by wesley so
knight c4 and now b4
by wesley soap but this just transposes
to what we were looking at
so black to move here has some difficult
questions to answer
the the most natural seems to be trying
to maintain the symmetry even further
for example with the move like b5
but here it's actually going to be white
who benefits by capturing on a6
first if you think you're going to take
here look out this b5 pawn
might end up hanging and also crucially
you might find yourself losing control
of the a file
for example rook a8 here rook takes a8
queen takes a8
knight d7 is unplayable and white is
gonna have
very much a distinct edge with control
over the only open
well one of the only open files on the
board while the c file remains blocked
and by the way there are other ways to
continue here with white as well
but this rook a1 idea i think is enough
to be scary of
scared of so after b4 magnus carlsen
captures back on c5 and i would like to
ask you chat room
pawn takes or pawn takes
how do you want to capture this knight
on c5
one of these moves maintains a slight
edge
one of these moves does not the chat
room was informing me informing me
that carlson's last lost was in beale of
july of 2018.
i think this was played checking my
notes here in
june of 2018. so almost his last loss
but not quite
before the long streak of course he has
since lost
to polish phenom yon kristoff
duda
pip and chuck likes pawn takes and
so the correct way to capture this pawn
is in fact
with the d-pawn which to my eyes at
first is very counter-intuitive
you'd never well okay i shouldn't say
never because you do want to here but
you
usually don't want to capture away from
the center you don't want to give up
control
of the center and so b takes c5 would be
the more natural approach
as chess king in the chat says you also
open up the b
file for some ideas of attacking this b7
pawn
however black can almost immediately
neutralize
all threats with the move b6 now if
white tries to win this pawn
well it's not going to be your pawn for
long black is winning it back on the c5
square
and this is what you might expect
from a boring exchange love draw
so b6 really crucial idea here
for black to just sort of liquidate
everything now against
d takes c4 this b6 idea isn't going to
go over
quite as well for example bishop c4 dc4
now we can trade queens and what's the
difference with this
well now we can take this guy go knight
e5
and this pawn is going to suffer
dual threats of knight d7 and capturing
on
c4 so white would be winning a upon here
so d takes c4 in this case the correct
way to go
although i would say i do think the
chatroom's instincts of b takes c5
are in fact the right way to to think
it's just that specifically here you do
have to take with the d
pawn to prevent this idea of b6
now magnus was perhaps thinking well
wait what's the big idea
i attacked a pawn and it's not defended
so he took a free pawn and chat room
what was the big idea uh why did we give
up this pawn
what is the point how are we actually
surviving this position
with white for the moment it looks like
we're down upon our opponent has more
center pawns than we do
we perhaps have a strong pawn on c5
but no very clear way to take advantage
of this
so what do you think chat how do we
continue
and notably if b takes c5 and knight
takes a3
white or black would have to deal with a
lot of the same counter play and perhaps
it would even be stronger
for uh for white there which is why
b6 was the crucial idea
chess king asks did wesley blunder i am
going to go with
no i think he still had things under
control here
uh perhaps the best idea is what the
chat room is suggesting
the the simple something like queen a4
or queen b3
probably was was the way to go for
example queen b3
if knight back to b5 can actually
capture this piece
and again it's going to be a relevant a
file
and also very importantly this is sort
of an awkward fork
for black to deal with queen d7 for
example
we can snap on a5 and you don't really
feel the extra pawn in this position for
black
you just feel the extra weaknesses so
white would be doing quite well here and
perhaps better for black is to just
sacrifice
the pawn back immediately with something
like this
but then you're gonna get something
similar to what we see in the game
where wesley wins the pawn back and is
just enjoying a pleasant space advantage
instead
wesley starts with the move knight d4
which doesn't really spoil anything
but now after bishop e4 if you want to
go for these same
ideas uh i think you do first
need to kick away this bishop from the
e4 square
so it sort of enticed wesley into
playing the move f3
which all things being equal perhaps
isn't the greatest move to have included
that's really the only difference
between the immediate queen b3 and queen
a4
and playing knight d4 first is being
enticed to play this move f3
the bishop comes back to g6 now we do
see queen b3
knight c4 we take take and
queen takes and now this is the position
on the table so once again
all from a boring exchange love we've
now
seen upon sacrifice by a white which has
since been recouped
we see extra space for white on the
queen side
but we do see black with the bishop pair
and we see white with
potentially some king side weaknesses
with this move f3
included so what's actually going on
here
well it turns out this is in fact just
going to be very good
for wesley the game continued with queen
to e8
perhaps not really sensing the danger
was magnus carlsen
it's actually time for black to sort of
beg for trades with something like
bishop g5
and after takes takes the weaknesses on
the king's side do start
to be felt white has to go for something
like f4
a simple queen retreat is uh called for
here
and black's bishop at least can play on
this open diagonal
white is probably still a bit better
here with great squares
for the night great potential for the
knight but once again you do feel some
weaknesses around the white king
instead we see queenie 8 by the world
champion
and the simple bishop retreat bishop g3
by
wesley now after e5 forcing the knight
away
the knight just comes back to to b3 we
see bishop d8 now
and perhaps this is the greatest sign
that something has gone wrong
for black the pieces just keep moving
backwards
there's nowhere to put the black pieces
queen d5 is wesley so's move and after
queen b5
uh wesley is actually the one going up
upon here don't even think
about taking this pawn on b4 you're
going to get slammed by the move bishop
d6
with c6 bam not so happy here
for magnus
when of course b8 queen is difficult to
stop
um so queen takes b4 this is perhaps
what magnus missed with this queen b5
idea but now after bishop b7
simply queen d2 wesley is up a pawn this
bishop
comes into d6 further staying in black's
face
bishop f6 now if you take this guy
then c takes d6 and this d pawn is
simply going to be too strong
in the game bishop f6 now e4 and you
really don't feel the bishop pair
here either for black all of the
imbalances do seem to be
favoring white in this case uh h6 was
played the knight comes back to d4 now
with the absence of the e5 pawn
and this is just a crush like no other
rook fee one played
king h7 and now once again chat
we've done the hard work we have a great
advantage in our position
against magnus carlson but how do we put
the world champion away
how do we put him out of this game uh
because there are some problems left
for white to solve number one white has
great
fantastic controls control over the dark
squares
right we have the dark squared bishop
against the light squared bishop
but it is a little bit unclear
how we make progress here our extra pawn
is not a past pawn and it's very
difficult to make it a past pawn
so white to move and come up with a
winning plan
what can you do
what can you do
and yeah you guys definitely have the
right idea here
you would love to go f4 f5 but
you don't want to jump the gun you don't
want to jump the gun at all after
f4 black has a very nice defensive
resource
that you guys might have not counted on
so
if you play f4 immediately now black to
move
and stay in the game with the fight
f4 i'm willing to call mistake white's
still better
white's up upon white's always going to
be better but
f4 does make things a bit more difficult
so of course the uh drawing or not
drawing resource
the defensive resource is f5 you know if
you don't stop this move by black black
is going to play it anyways
what's the point of f5 how does it make
sense to put even more pawns on the same
color as black's bishop
well the point is if we can induce e5
now we're going to reroute this bishop
to e6
and black's claim is that he has a nice
light square blockade
set up and this is absolutely the worst
thing to see
if you're playing with opposite colored
bishops and you have the extra material
at all costs you should be looking to
stop this type of light square blockade
which is why wesley starts with a very
accurate move g4
you want to stop f5 before going for
yourself
very important to uh to note so
uh g4 is a great move by wesley
now f6 by magnus nothing to fear now
from f5 now that we control this square
so f4 by wesley is the idea
queen c6 was magnus's choice but now f5
bishop f7 and the hits sort of keep
coming here
so you did a great job of advancing your
king side pawns
but once again how to continue how do
you continue this position
there's something really important in
positions with bishops of opposite
colors
specifically when there are major pieces
left on the board
so that thing that is crucial
to positions of bishops of opposite
colors with major pieces on the board
is of course the safety of the kings so
we would love to play the move e5
and break through creating a past pawn
but this
does start to keep things a bit airy
around
the white king opening up files like
this and after f takes c
bishop takes e for example it's still
not super clear
how we're actually going to break
through with uh white
and in fact black may even have crazy
ideas
like g6 here to start breaking down the
pawns further and further
and as the kingside pawns disappear yes
black's king gets weaker but so does
white's king and that's sort of
double-edged stuff
that you really should be looking to
avoid um
same thing with a question that i just
saw if f4 f5
e takes f again you have this move
of g4 but even here perhaps
something like queen d3 could be
considered and if you go f5 here bishop
f7
and we're looking at almost an identical
position to what we just saw
so g4 definitely the way to start and
here
not the move e5 but we use this pawn to
help limit black's activity
on e4 that's where it's the most useful
instead
white is going to push h4 and look to
open up the king
in this manner why is this better than
e5 with the same goal
well e5 does more to activate black's
pieces than it does to activate
whites whereas this idea does more to
activate white's pieces
100 so it's all about looking for ways
to favorably
uh open up the position um
magnus tried rook to a8 which is a good
try as any very difficult to find moves
here for
black wesley plays the move rook c2 just
a subtlety to give this rick access on
the second rank
a5 by black this was magnus's point with
rook a8
but now g5 comes and bishop h5
activates the bishop again but now g6
and the king is sort of locked in a
jail cell um how is it going to get out
not so
clear wesley now continues with the move
b5
with the point being we have gotten huge
advantages on the king's side
if the white major pieces get into the
seventh rank or especially the eighth
rank
black is just going to be checkmated so
wesley starts opening up files
giving his pieces access to this queen
side
queen takes b5 was played rook b2 queen
back to c6
rook b6 now queen c8
queen d5 and this pawn is already
becoming indefensible
for example rook a7 uh perhaps the
simplest is just rook e
to b1 but maybe even better is queen f7
with similar ideas but also just you
know balancing those ideas
with check mating threats as well it's
difficult to even suggest a move here
for black for example
a4 and now the time might be right
for a crucial breakthrough
although okay wait a second wait a
second i don't want to allow this
don't want to allow this so maybe this
is the crucial breakthrough instead that
is winning the game
um but in the game after queen d5
magnus perhaps realized this queen of
seven move was so powerful and
everything was so powerful and he just
plays a4
wesley just takes this pawn on b7 and
rook takes g7 is now a threat
so rook g8 played c6 and magnus had seen
enough
and went ahead and resigned this game
so what happened this game why did
magnus just get rolled over
well a lot of things happened stretching
back
to this idea of knight d7 by
black this is the type of active idea by
black to try to go with g5
but when successfully parried we once
again see
that white is just seemingly a few tempi
ahead
over here on the queen side and is able
to turn that into a favorable
imbalance so if you think the exchange
slav
is the type of boring opening where you
can do whatever you want
you are mistaken it is a very urgent
opening
in many cases where both sides really
need to rush
in order to make use of the queen side
play
in this case wesley's play was just
coming a little bit
too quickly for magnus to handle as far
as the move
that really gave up the advantage uh
it's sort of difficult to say to be
honest with you it's sort of difficult
to say
i i would think here already uh white is
definitely a bit better
maybe if the move bishop g5 has been
played black is still in the game
but honestly it's it's tough to say what
exactly
went wrong for black maybe this knight
d7 idea
is just a little bit flawed a little bit
too slow
and that might just be the case um other
than that
uh yeah i don't know it's tough wesley
just played like a near perfect game of
chess here
and that's what you have to do to be the
world champion
but yeah definitely bishop g5 would have
been a lot better than queen e8 bishop
g5 keeps black in the game
so if you want to highlight a move that
really sort of uh
sent it in the wrong direction i think
queenie 8 was that move
does white have uh bishop b7 instead of
my suggestion of e5
so okay at the very end i was just sort
of playing through some moves to
highlight the ideas
probably bishop e7 is winning but maybe
there's some craziness here bishop takes
g6 gotta really be careful of this
i don't know i don't know what's going
on i don't know
there's definitely stuff to be careful
of though so maybe e5
is just the way the way to do things by
the way c6 is also good
c6 is also good white's just sort of
crushing it
which is why the game ended in two moves
nice ten part series about the slob
that's where you're wrong it's about the
semi-sloth
which i believe is able to avoid this
exchange slot
move order it's just too powerful just
too powerful
um okay um jonathan hart says i was
gonna end there but this question is too
funny
he says i would love to see you analyze
some of your own games on your road 2000
has that been done could we see that and
i've been doing this class
for so long that i swear to you pretty
much
almost all of my games are have have
been analyzed i obviously haven't been
playing too many
more games recently with over-the-board
chess being a
dead sport but um yeah definitely i can
bring back some more over the board
games
but i really have analyzed many of them
already so go through the vods if that's
what you want to see if you want to see
more of my games i recommend that
but uh for now trying to keep things
interesting
with some some new topics but
that is where i'm gonna have to end it
today if you guys
are still interested in more chess stick
around for the end game class last
endgame class i took you through some
basic rook end games
um basic meaning sort of
bare bones rook end games with only one
pawn on the board and tonight we're
going to take a look at some really
really important rook end games
but also some pretty tough ones but
they're important to understand
so i'm going to take you through those
in the endgame class right up next
highly recommend you guys all stick
around for it
other than that that is where i am going
to end
tonight's show thank you guys so much
for watching as always my name is caleb
denby
and i will see you next time
you